[Musik]
herzlich willkommen die richtigen fragen
hierbei bild und ja was sind schon hohe
spritpreise was sind schon ein paar
leere supermarktregale gegen tausende
tote in der ukraine ja das stimmt und
doch spüren wir hier mittlerweile die
auswirkungen des ukraine krieges ganz
direkt bei ein paar lehren
supermarktregalen beim speiseöl beim
sonnenblume beim rapsöl ok kleinigkeiten
aber beim spritpreis einige lebensmittel
werden rationiert mittlerweile bei edeka
bei rewe und so weiter beim spritpreis
hört für viele deutsche der spaß auf das
geht richtig ran ans portemonnaie wie
viel wohlstand kostet uns jetzt schon
putins krieg darüber sprechen wir mit
diesen gästen hier in den richtigen
fragen nämlich mit dem fdp-fraktionschef
christian dürr mit jens spahn der hier
im studio ist der sich hauptberuflich
seit einiger zeit nicht mehr und corona
kümmert sondern um die wirtschaft um die
klimapolitik für die union und ralf
stegner ist uns zugeschaltet herzlich
willkommen an sie alle hätten wie viel
wohlstand kostet uns putins krieg
das können wir jetzt noch gar nicht
ausmachen und genau ausrechnen leider
klar ist es braucht wirtschaftliche
stärke damit man so etwas stemmen kann
deutschland ist zum glück im grundsatz
gut aufgestellt aber da werden wir
gleich noch reden bei den energiepreisen
waren wir leider auch schon vor diesem
ukraine krieg sehr hochpreisig unterwegs
und das hat menschen der vergangenheit
belastet jetzt natürlich umso mehr
insbesondere an der zapfsäule insofern
müssen wir genau hinschauen
darüber reden wir sicherlich gleich noch
aber ein solcher krieg hat natürlich
auch ökonomische auswirkungen es werden
lieferketten unterbrochen und leider
merken dass auch die menschen als ampel
versuchen wir das so gut wie möglich
abzufedern die sind gut aufgestellt ist
so ein bisschen phrasen mäßig deswegen
ganz ehrlich ersparen was wird uns das
kosten wie viel wohlstand wird uns der
ukraine krieg kosten nun das ist jetzt
natürlich noch viel stochern im nebel
weil wir eine sehr sehen es hat
auswirkungen wir hatten übrigens feuer
schon themen rund um lieferketten etwa
wir haben lieferzeiten bei fahrrädern
schon vorher gehabt von 40 50 wochen zum
teil in der kroner pandemie sind
lieferketten gerissen die sind bis heute
noch nicht wieder richtig voll im gange
und das verstärkt das jetzt natürlich
noch mal enorm wir haben viele
unternehmer in deutschland die auf
russische auch für produkte zum teil
angewiesen sind in bestimmten bereichen
im agrarbereich bei holz bei anderen
themen und insofern werden wir das
spüren was das wirklich toll mit
rezession was das wirklich ausmacht es
schwer zu sagen
was wir ja sehen ist die lieferbeziehung
mit russland also der wirtschaftliche
austausch ins gesamte handel der ist für
deutschland jetzt nicht so sind wenige
prozent vom bruttoinlandsprodukt der ist
jetzt nicht so dass das wahrscheinlich
uns richtig tief unterzieht generell was
es aber ein ganz entscheidender stelle
sind energielieferungen beim thema gas
kohle öl spüren wir es halt sehr sehr
deutlich also insgesamt der handel mit
russland ist etwas da würde ich sagen
das tut weh aber das halten wir aus
wirtschaftlich aber weil es eben diese
spezielle starke abhängigkeit beim thema
energie gibt ich bin bei den teils sehr
sehr witzig so jahr rechnen sie damit
dass es halt und kann heute ernsthaft
noch niemand sagen womit zu rechnen es
ist eine noch weiter steigende inflation
das ist ja das was für viele bürgerinnen
und bürger ganz konkret spürbar ist die
preise steigen und zwar nicht nur an der
zapfsäule oder haben wir ja schon fünf
prozent schon einmal 15.2 zeigen bei den
lebensmitteln sie steigen in anderen
bereichen und das wird sich im zweifel
noch verstärken übrigens ein prozent
mehr inflation heißt zehn milliarden
euro mehreinnahmen bei den steuern für
den staat und deswegen ist die forderung
auch klar die sanktionen sollen ja nicht
putin treffen sollen putin treffen nicht
die pendler so die sanktionen sollen
nicht die pendler treffen sondern putin
und deswegen müssen wir die pendler eben
entlasten die bürgerinnen und bürger der
staat verdient gerade mehr über diesen
gestiegenen preisen und deswegen sollte
er auch etwas zurückgeben da gehen wir
gleich richtig rein ersparen die
forderung die vor allen dingen natürlich
an die ampel hier geht an ralf stegner
an christian doerr verstehen aber noch
einmal die frage haben sie schon eine
ungefähre ahnung wo das hingehen könnte
schleudern wir hier in die rezession
rein wie viel inflation wird das bringt
ich glaube das kann man seriös nicht
sagen und ich finde ein bisschen
erstaunt mit welcher sicherheit manche
menschen schon formulieren was alles
falsch oder was jetzt zu tun soll was
genau passiert wäre das wieder
zeitenwende akzeptiert und es ist ja so
ein krieg von dem wir nicht wissen wie
lange dauert und mit ihm viele nicht
gerechnet haben er kann jetzt auch
unmöglich sagen es passiert genau das
oder jenes schön finde ich sowohl
schnelle forderungen als auch die
sicheren anderen ein bisschen überzogen
zumal man ja sagen muss dass das ein
außenpolitische krise ist wo wir alle
gesagt hat wir müssen jetzt solidarität
üben mit der ukraine
wir wollen gemeinsame aktion harte
sanktionen gegen russland
miteinander verabreden ja jahren von
denen wir von den sanktionen von denen
wir uns immer wussten das auch gesagt
worden die treffen keineswegs nur putin
und seine leute sondern sie treffen uns
auch manche sagen sogar sie müssen uns
auch dreßen des wilden kaisers regner
deswegen januar ehrlichkeit und rita
dieser prognosen beispielsweise ihr haus
und hof
wirtschaftsexperte vom bbw marcel
fritsche der spricht schon von bis zu
zehn prozent inflation beispielsweise
also das ist ja schon eine voraussage
die oft ich war ja auch seriös ist seit
der finanzinstitute ja ich weiß es ja
noch mehr trotz einer gewissen skepsis
gegenüber der sicherheit ich würde eher
formulieren wir müssen uns darauf
einrichten dass das sehr sehr schwierig
werden kann ohne jetzt schon
horrormeldungen oder vor davor einige
soll abrüstung da verkünden zu können
ich glaube wir müssen uns darauf
einrichten dass es eine sehr harte
periode werden kann und das ist in der
tat sagen kann je länger das dauert das
nachhaltigen einfluss hat und dass in
der rezession drohen können dass man
deswegen dann auch was dagegen tun kann
was ich nicht so gut finde sondern auf
der einen seite solidarität einfordert
auf maßnahmen von adidas noch erschweren
und dann aber gleich als opposition
kommt und sagt das muss die regierung
jetzt tun damit das geschieht und ich
will versuchen wir auch noch ein na ja
darum ist ja schon jahren hersteller
sofort hätten ersparen es geht ja darum
dass sich auch die bürger einfach auf
was einstellen müssen also es geht ja
nicht nur darum über zahlen zu reden und
was möglicherweise im jahr ist sondern
jetzt ganz konkret müssen ja millionen
deutsche genau diesen erhöhten
spritpreis beispielsweise zahlen und da
war in der vergangenen woche gerade und
zwar ganz genau sieben tage ist es her
da war hier auf dem stuhl vorn jens
spahn christian lindner zu gast der
bundesfinanzminister und hat ganz klar
gesagt was er von einer spritpreis
bremse von sinkenden steuern auf
spritpreis hält
also es gibt keinerlei überlegungen
derzeit die steuern auf sprit zu senken
ein
klarer hässlich sein können die antwort
in glas klares nein von der politik
erhofft man sich klare antworten das war
so eine auch wenn sie vielen nicht
geschmeckt hat jetzt kommt aber heute
ein frischer gedanke von christian
lindner reihen sieben tage danach er
twittert dass hier heute und kündigt
zusätzliche weitere entlastung an der
letzte satz von diesem typ der es
entscheidend dass die koalition nämlich
in kürze weitere maßnahmen beschließen
werde zur entlastung da müssen sie uns
einmal helfen härter ist jetzt innerhalb
von sieben tagen innerhalb von zwanzig
oder dreißig cent auf den spritpreis aus
dem glas klar nein ein jahr geworden
also zunächst mal müssen wir zwei dinge
auseinanderhalten erstens wir haben ein
erbe angetreten
von der bisherigen großen koalition und
16 jahre unionsgeführte dass wir uns
ganz kurz bei der klaren frage ist
leider das ist jetzt ganz stark weil
weil da ja ganz konkrete frage oder
lindner hatten wir noch schafft klare
antworten
man muss man muss aber die dinge schon
im zusammenhang sehen sonst werden
antworten unsinnig und deswegen lassen
sie mich das ganz kurz sagen erstens die
krasse abhängigkeit die macht sich jetzt
gerade an der zapfsäule bemerkbar war
ein riesenfehler in der vergangenheit
auch beim thema gas zweiter leider haben
wir auch 16 jahre unionsgeführte
bundesregierung mit stark gestiegenen
energiepreisen wir hatten ja schon vor
diesem furchtbaren krieg die höchsten
energiepreise in europa auch übrigens
eine zapfsäule und auf der stromrechnung
und ja natürlich schaut sich die ampel
das an erstens was wir gemacht haben 16
milliarden entlastungspaket das ist ja
noch gar nicht in gang gesetzt und so
das wird die inflation immer gleich man
kriegt man auch der richtige gewesen das
wird lassen lassen wir das doch ganz
kurz im zusammenhang erläutern damit es
auch für die zuschauer sinn macht an der
stelle mit dass nachvollziehbar ist was
ich hier sage wir werden jetzt ein
entlastungspaket was wir beschlossen
haben politisch auf den weg bringen und
rückwirkend zum ersten januar 2022
entlastung in höhe von 16 milliarden auf
den weg bringen und das war es christian
lindner heute gesagt hat weil die
entwicklung ebenso dynamisch ist dass
man dann auch sagen muss man muss noch
mal nachsteuern
wir werden weiter schauen welche anderen
belastungen in den letzten 16 jahren
drauf gekommen sind durch die groko und
durch die unionsgeführte bundesregierung
die man jetzt wieder zurückdreht damit
man kurzfristig den menschen an der
zapfsäule strom und beim gast entlasten
kann das machen sie aber das machen wir
aber dass nämlich das auch sagen an der
stelle jetzt nicht in der öffentlichkeit
damit danach nichts passiert so hat ja
die groko viele jahre regiert in berlin
groß diskutiert sich gestritten und dann
nichts entschieden sondern wir werden
das jetzt intern besprechen und ist dann
anschauen welche einzelnen belastungen
auf dem spritpreis beispielsweise wieder
zurückgenommen werden müssen damit wir
auf faire preise haben zumindest
angesichts der umstände okay das waren
jetzt drei minuten fast ganz viel
parteienstreit hätten nehmen sie es mir
nicht krumm aber sie sagen das werden
wir jetzt nicht in der öffentlichkeit
diskutieren ihr finanzminister hat das
ja heute gemacht der hat das ja
getwittert das ist ja anlass jetzt noch
mal zusätzlich für unsere debatte haben
sie ersparen jetzt verstanden was da
kommen könnte weil die frage ist ja und
die kommt hundertfach alleine bei uns
von unseren zuschauern an singt jetzt
der steueranteil auf den spritpreis ja
oder nein das habe ich jetzt gerade noch
nicht verstanden habe ich auch noch
nicht verstanden der finanzminister hat
er geschafft heute zwei positionen heute
schon zu haben heute morgen in einem
interview hat er gesagt die preise
werden nicht gesenkt das wird nichts
gemacht so wie letzte woche bei ihnen
auch ein nein heute wahrscheinlich hat
die fdp intern viel miteinander
diskutiert er gab es dann diesen tweet
der was ankündigte man muss sich ja
erinnern das weiß auch christian dürr
wenn eine partei in den letzten jahren
auch im bundestagswahlkampf immer wieder
und ich würde sogar sagen an manchen
stellen zu recht die entlastung der
bürgerinnen und bürger angemahnt hat
dann war es die fdp und kaum stellt sie
den finanzminister ist jeder euro mehr
für den staat ein guter euro das passt
nicht und deswegen gerade bei den
spritpreisen bei den energiepreisen post
ist jetzt konkrete entlastungen da geht
es auch nicht wie herr stegner gerade
gesagt hat müssen wir mal schauen was
sich noch entwickelt gab heute vor
einigen vorhin in köln getankt 2 eur 33
hat da der liter gekostet wenn du 50
liter tanks bist du schon fast bei 120
euro und das trifft viele bei mir im
münsterland in deutschland insgesamt
pendler familien
jeder der irgendwie mal tanken muss
überlegt sich mittlerweile ob er das tun
kann und diese bürgerinnen und bürger
brauchen entlastung jetzt in denen der
spritpreis mindestens mal und noch mal
ganz klar endlager stand doch eigentlich
nur eins sagen da vor der tür wird
gleich sagen haushaltsmittel braucht es
dafür sorry ich sage noch einmal ein
prozent inflation zehn milliarden euro
steuern mehr und gerade auch jetzt bei
den gestiegenen energiepreisen bei der
mehrwertsteuer automatisch verdient der
staat mit russischer hand geld
zurückzugeben dass der staat
ungerechtfertigterweise mehr hat und von
herrn stegner erwarte ich das gar nicht
von der fdp erwarte ich dass jetzt die
bürgerinnen und bürger entlastet da
hängt ja also herr spahn ist gleich
schlag kommen ist eine opposition ist
sehr schlau geworden so wie
hans im saarland der dann forsch
tankstellen ja populistische ansagen
macht der punkt ist er natürlich hat
darauf hingewiesen wir haben ein
entlastungspaket beschlossen das wirkt
noch gar nicht das wird kommen da wird
entlastung bei der pendlerpauschale zum
beispiel geben das wird aber nicht
ausgleichen wir haben die
wirtschaftsinstitute schon gesagt werden
freibeträge erhöht und ich habe herrn
lindner nicht so verstanden dass das hat
der steueranteil wird gesenkt hat gesagt
wenn über andere entlastungsmaßnahmen zu
reden haben insbesondere bei denen die
viel fahren müssen bei denen die geringe
und normale einkommen haben da gibt es
verschiedene bereiten wir noch die als
pauschale die hilfen erhöhen die wir
schon beschlossen haben dass da kann
über noch etwas draufgelegt werden aber
eine eins roadshows sozusagen mal soeben
angekündigt wenn jemand der gerade in
die opposition gewechselt ist das ist
billig und so werden wir das auch nicht
machen so wie wenn das solide
miteinander diskutieren und dann wird
zum in den maßnahmen paket geben für das
nunmehr sie nennen das was ersparen sagt
billig das was sie gerade machen ist
ziemlich teuer wir können uns noch mal
auf den auf die säule uns einmal
vergewissern wie hoch ist aktuell liege
der steueranteil auf den sprit gucken
wir uns noch mal genau an hätte wie das
aktuell aussieht wir haben einmal als
richtwert ein literpreis von 2 eur 9
genommen und da sehen wir dass da immer
noch mehr steuer drin steckt in diesem
lied als tatsächlich rohölpreis also
alles was gelb und rot ist gehört
sozusagen dem finanzminister erst mal
und alles was grau ist der ölpreis den
können sie derzeit kaum beeinflussen und
von dem riesigen batzen gibt es im
moment nichts herr zugegeben hätte
nein so ist es ja nicht und mit verlaub
das was ihnen sparen gerade gemacht hat
das war leider auch populismus das waren
krokodilstränen also das ergebnis was
sie gerade an die wand geworfen haben
ist ja 16 jahre unionsgeführte
bundesregierung aber das einmal doch
gehört der schulter das stimmt sogar
und das stimmt da hat herr spahn eine
riesen verantwortung mitzutragen wenn
ich weiter und die kundenvermögen man
festhalten dass für den krieg putin
verantwortlich ist und für den überfall
auf
das für die folge verantwortlich ist und
vielleicht können wir ja auch festhalten
das könnte jetzt noch alles so machen
das macht er ja in der ampelkoalition
jetzt seit drei monaten in jeder debatte
16 jahre das könnte vielleicht noch drei
monate länger machen aber eins müsste
halt jetzt mal schon akzeptiert ihr habt
gar regiert jetzt es regiert die fdp
weiter stark und deswegen löst die
probleme nicht
konkret löst sie reden gerade an den
zuschauern vorbei herr dürr sparen sie
reden an den zuschauern vorbei ist
einfach für die zeit nach elisabeth
aufgaben ein punkt sagen herr weise
wurde wurde er sparen einfach was
falsches gerade in der öffentlichkeit
gesagt hat er hat gerade behauptet der
staat hat krasse mehreinnahmen summer so
marx und jens spahn ist viel schlauer
als dass er weiß nämlich dass natürlich
die gestiegenen kosten auch gegen
gewinnsteuern gerechnet werden der staat
hat an anderer stelle und das sind keine
krokodilstränen jetzt von meiner seite
ich will es noch einmal feststellen weil
jens spahn behaupte das wären alles
durch mehr einnahmen denkbar das ist
schlicht die unwahrheit gewesen was er
gerade gesagt hat denn wir haben an
anderer stelle nicht krasse
mindereinnahmen dh wer jetzt sagt dieser
steuer ein teil des staates der muss
quasi abgeschafft werden der muss schon
sagen die bayern sparen wo das ganze
heer kommt es ist nicht die wahrheit
dass der staat summa summarum zurzeit
mehr einen er nicht gerade weniger an
wir werden das bei der kommenden
steuerschätzung sehen und noch mal ich
bin sehr dafür sieht das genauso wie der
kollege stegner das ist eine ampel neben
den 16 milliarden die wir jetzt auf den
weg bringen werden in den kommenden
wochen dass wir dann eben uns auch diese
energie steuern der alten koalition und
insbesondere der hätte den bundestrainer
noch wir haben ja hier und da haben wir
hier 45 minuten da los ist haben wir ja
dabei stelle die warmen auto dieser
einfachen frage wir nehmen uns noch mal
diesen steueranteil auf sprit vor da
gibt es jetzt sie können das
populistisch oder billig nennen da gibt
es eine klare antwort von jens sparen
darauf dass die steuern sinken müssen
tobias hans im saarland klar der steckt
im moment im wahlkampf aber der macht
lassen vorschlag der sagt 53 cent davon
runter letzte woche hier der
finanzminister christian lindner der
ganz klar sagt von diesen steuern wird
hier immer chronisch gesenkt heute in
dem irgendwie schon wieder anders und
ich möchte einfach verstehen wofür
stehen sie jetzt ist das ausgeschlossen
dass sie die steuern auf schritt senken
werden ja oder nein
es ist gar nichts ausgeschlossen aber
der konkrete vorschlag der union herr
weise war ein anderer der für konkrete
vorstand der union das hat der yen
sparen jetzt unter tisch fallen lassen
war ja an der mehrwertsteuer
insbesondere zu treten so habe ich eher
als den parteivorsitzenden friedrich
merz verstanden ja genau und mit verlaub
da haben wir ganz wunderbare erfahrung
so kroner gezeiten gemacht eine jetzt
wie von der union geforderte
vorübergehende mehrwertsteuer führt im
gegenteil dazu dass hier in der
mittelfristige inflation sogar noch
anheizen würden also mit verlaub man
muss schon sehr klug sagen welche
maßnahmen genau meint ja ich finde diese
ökosteuer stufen kann man sich noch mal
angucken die wie gesagt aus der zeit von
angela merkel und auch hier entspannt
und zum zweiten müssen natürlich schauen
wo wir an anderer stelle auch entlasten
können 16 milliarden bringen wir jetzt
gerade auf den weg also zu behaupten
gerade die fdp sei nicht für entlastung
ist geradezu lächerlich wir haben das in
den letzten jahren immer wieder
angemahnt da ist auch jens spahn nichts
dazu eingefallen natürlich ist es jetzt
absolut dringlich das was machen keine
frage nochmal wir besprechen das wie
ralf stegner es gesagt hat innerhalb der
ampel und kommt damit einem ergebnis
nach draußen was funktioniert was
menschen entlassen immer noch einmal 16
milliarden sind ein erster schritt über
weitere werden jetzt reden ok über
weitere werden sie reden das ist aber
noch mal verzeihen sie das ist so mühsam
ist aber es ist mit ihnen leute bisher
mühsam der finanzminister sagt
vergangene woche ganz klar nein damit
sagen sie einen hinweis noch mal die iss
geben ihr zeigen sie es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass heißt jetzt immer er
will das abschaffen nur wie wir das
eigentlich finanzieren das kann man im
finger habe ich mir vorher verstehen und
dass man sehr schwachen beantwortet er
immer endlich regiert der staaten aber
ein name aber sie müssen doch erklären
was sie wollen das hat herr sparen
zumindest an der stelle jetzt wo er
nicht mehr regiert marx tatsächlich
leichter fallen aber das hatte erklärt
er hat eine klare position ihrer hab ich
jetzt jetzt haben wir es schon hier 15
minuten ungefähr ich habe es einfach
noch nicht verstanden herr lindner hat
vergangene woche das ganz klar
ausgeschlossen sie sagen jetzt es ist
nichts ausgeschlossen also sinken jetzt
die steuern auf den spritpreis kommt
daher loch oder nicht
herr lindner hat es ja bezogen auf die
familie vor zitierte forderung auch von
vom cdu bundesvorsitzende friedrich merz
bei der mehrwertsteuer zu drehen ich
sage mit der mehrwertsteuersenkung die
dauert sehr lange bis sie wirkt da haben
wir schon mal schlechte erfahrungen
gemacht die anderen punkte gucken wir
uns an und wir schauen auch wie wir es
beispielsweise bei dem vorhin schon und
jetzt viel zitierten entlastungspaket
von 16 milliarden euro bei einer lokalen
gestalten noch einmal ganz kurz die tür
wäre darüber reden aber mit verlaub ich
kann ihnen heute nicht sagen welche
maßnahmen ist im detail sa stehen noch
einmal die eine ton von christian
lindner vergangene woche vor sieben
tagen ganz genau zeigen dass noch einmal
ganz kurz zur erinnerung
also es gibt keinerlei überlegungen
derzeit die steuern auf sprit zu senken
nein
und jetzt hat er gibt es aber diese
überlegungen richtig
es gibt überlegungen zu entlasten ob das
jetzt da ganz welche steuer ist genau
sein wird herr weise sie können mich
jetzt ein kind mal fragen nochmal ich
will am ende dass wir eine ampel das
hinter verschlossenen türen schnell
diskutieren damit wir schnell mit einer
entscheidung und ein lokal wirkung
heraus aber jetzt sind wir den richtigen
schritt weiter immer öffentlich
diskutiertes nichts passiert das machen
wir anders na ja finanzminister hatte
öffentlich gemacht heute in dem er
weitere schritte angekündigt hat herr
stegner aber vielleicht können sie
helfen sie stellen ja auch den einen
oder anderen minister und im übrigen
auch dem bundeskanzler vielleicht hat er
ja sogar auch als früher war
finanzminister in der frage der position
der punkt ist doch der dass es leicht
ist forderungen zu erheben und nicht zu
gucken welche wirkungen das hat uns
seriös ist dass man sich auf ein
massnahmenpaket verständlich dass herr
wird auch klar gesagt das ist die
meinung der ampel insgesamt dass wir die
bürger entlasten müssen gerade
diejenigen mit den normalen geringen
gehältern die die viel fahren müssen und
da geht es verschiedene möglichkeiten
das zu tun was haben wir davon wir
werden einer schraube drehen und die
mineralölkonzerne zum beispiel denken
gar nicht daran das weiterzugeben
sondern erhöhen im zweifelsfall ihre
preise und dann ist es am ende plus
minus null so was darf doch nicht
rauskommen am ende und deswegen werden
wir ihnen in kürze sagen welche form der
entlassung es gibt das ist eine gibt da
sind wir uns in der ampel völlig einigen
anders als zu sparen müssen wir auch
seriös machen das auch funktioniert geht
nach wenigen der forderungen erheben
sondern man muss das auch so umsetzen
ist auch die richtigen trifft kommt die
richtigen entlastet wie hast das finde
ich mich entscheiden das ist eine ganz
entscheidende frage lassen einmal
nachfragen ersparen bevor wir zu ihrer
finanzierung kommen und zwar das ist
wenn es darum geht die richtigen zu
treffen wie sie es sagen dann meinen sie
wahrscheinlich nicht zuerst herren
sparen der heute auch für 100 euro
getankt hat oder über 100 euro wie er
gerade verraten hat geht das denn beim
spritpreis überhaupt dass man eine
schnelle wirkung also ganz schnell
entlastet das die menschen tatsächlich
eine schnelle erleichterung haben an der
tankstelle und das ist trotzdem nicht
einfach rasenmäher ist und alle
gleichermaßen entlastet sondern
tatsächlich die die es brauchen da gibt
es ja verschiedene instrumente über die
geld haben ich habe schon von der
pendler gesprochen die das sind die
besonders betroffenen natürlich
besonders weite wege zu fahren haben und
aufs auto angewiesen dass im ländlichen
raum ja teilweise wirklich der fall ist
kann man kurzfristig nicht ändern
deswegen haben uns darauf verständigt in
der koalition und so ist es mit anderen
dingen auch wo man geringverdiener
gezielt entlastet auch da haben wir
sonst verschiedenes
verständigt am kern im kern geht es
darum nicht wo man was bezahlt sondern
was am monatsende sozusagen noch im
geldbeutel ist und wenn es besondere
belastungen durch die kriegssituation
durch diese aktion gibt dann müssen wir
die bürgerinnen und bürger von denen wir
wissen dass sie besonders belastet sind
versuchen zu entlassen daran arbeiten
wir mit verschiedenen maßnahmen und am
ende wird es ein vernünftiges paket sein
und ich lasse mich nicht zu viel zeit
weil in der zeit muss man ja auch tanken
in der ganzen zeit und muss man die
rechnung bezahlt der krieg geht jetzt 14
tage und ja es ist in der tat 18
entschuldigung haben wir sind dabei
haben das erste entlastungspaket schon
beschlossen das zweite wird in kürze
folgen damit nicht ganz sicher dass wir
zu einer vernünftigen lösung kommen wie
viel zeit nehmen sich dafür wenn sie es
schon sagen dass es schnell geht herr
stegner hätte sicher wenige tage wenige
tage also im kabinett beispielsweise am
mittwoch spielt das schon eine rolle
hätte er nicht wir werden politischen
hat der ampel diese wochen darüber reden
das ist doch klar weil natürlich die
zeit drängt logisch es waren jetzt sind
sie dran mit der finanzierung natürlich
ist die frage völlig berechtigt sie
müssen es jetzt nicht mehr bezahlen und
können ganz locker mal forderungen
aufstellen da das die opposition erst
recht wenn man in einem kleinen
bundesland regiert und gerade im
wahlkampf ist und die umfragen nicht so
gut sind tobias hans da sagt man dann
schnell mal 53 cent runter vom
spritpreis aber das ding ist nicht zu
bezahlen sagen die kollegen dürren
stegner nicht nur erstmal eins vorweg
sagen da verweise ich bin jetzt immer
noch nicht richtig schlau wie denn die
bürgerinnen und bürger entlastet werden
sollen aber 10
doch nicht ja überall 1 darf halt nicht
passieren das höre ich ja irgendwie
schon so aus dass es nicht beim
spritpreis passiert also wenn man
irgendwie sagt wir denken jetzt ich weiß
nicht was und haben vielleicht auch ein
paar pendler die dabei entlastet werden
dann ist das einfach zu wenig sorry dass
beim tanken fallen die hohen kosten an
und beim tanken fallen die hohen steuern
an sie haben es ja gerade eingeblendet
mineralölsteuer co2 abgabe aber vor
allem auch die mehrwertsteuer die beim
gestiegenen preis höher ist und da muss
auch die entlastung ansetzen also wenn
es nachher heißt wir machen was bei der
kalten progression also im steuertarif
dann musste man das sowieso machen
übrigens aber dann hilft das jetzt
erstmal nicht denjenigen die jeden tag
tanken müssen und das ist unsere
erwartungen formulieren wir als
opposition ja aber die formulierung vor
allem als jemand der auch eine ländliche
region vertritt wo familien und ich sage
noch einmal es geht um geringverdiener
ja aber es geht auch um normalverdiener
durchschnittseinkommen um leute die
handwerker sind die facharbeiter sind
die meister sind die eine familie zu
ernähren haben die sich im moment das
tanken und das heizen kaum noch leisten
können und deswegen muss man konkret an
der stelle ansetzt ist jetzt keine
priorität in der ampel das haben wir
gelernt aber sie müssen es halt müssten
sie dann addieren finanzierung ist sagt
einmal die co2 abgabe wie auch die
steuern sind natürlich deutlich höher
auf energie moment als sie wären ohne
diesen krieg ohne die gestiegenen preise
allein die eeg-umlage kann dieses jahr
ja schon kostenneutral abgeschafft
werden weil eben zu den ersten monaten
dieses jahres ist so viel mehr einnahmen
gegeben hat bei der eeg umlage als es
eigentlich hätte gebraucht das heißt
also viel von dem was bis jetzt an
entlastung angekündigt wird ist gar
keine richtige entlastung sondern
finanziert sich aus dem was bis jetzt zu
viel gezahlt worden ist etwa bei der
eeg-umlage und genauso ist das genauso
ist das hier eben bei den spritpreisen
auch marga entschuldigungen kann doch
jetzt den entschuldigen
ich habe jetzt auch statt wenn sie mir
die chance geben man kann auch jetzt bei
den spritpreisen nicht sagen weil bei
den gewinnen bei den unternehmen es
möglicherweise solche händler grad
verstanden ja in einer wirtschaftlich
schwierigen phase ist einbrüche gibt
sollen jetzt die pendler das war ja mal
die wortwahl auch von koalitionären ein
opfer bringen in dieser zeit ich sage
noch einmal die sanktionen sollen putin
vor allem treffen sollen vor allem die
oligarchen treffen aber nicht die
pendler in deutschland und ja da ist
meine erwartung und wenn gewünscht es
helfen würde auch gerne konkret mit und
gehen noch mit in die verantwortung wenn
es gute vorschläge sind meine erwartung
dass das auch konkret an der zapfsäule
passiert das heißt ersparen würde es
ihnen sogar mit durchrechnen herr
stegner würde ihnen sogar helfen würde
ihnen beim gesetzesentwurf helfen noch
seien sie müssen sich dann großzügig bin
ganz begeistert und will auf dieser
großzügigkeit aber ersparen fordern das
eine schliesst das andere sofort aus der
science muss unbedingt genau da sein und
nirgendwo anders ich finde es ist
seriöser zu sagen dass die menschen die
am ende weniger im geldbeutel haben
entlastet werden und wie wir das machen
im paket von verschiedenen maßnahmen
wird so ausgestaltet dass ist auch nutzt
und jetzt und nicht so wie herr sparen
wer sich hinstellt und einfache
forderung erhebt und gar nicht
verantwortlich ist für das am ende raus
und es wären wir auch ohne positionen
schaffen ich glaube nur weil wir nicht
wissen wieder in der krieg dauert weil
wir nicht wissen wie sich das auswirken
wird weiter mit den sanktionen dass wir
uns darauf einrichten müssen dass das
was wir machen hilft das ist konkret
hilft dass es keine schüsse sind und es
geht nicht darum dass der staat mehr
verdienen will davon kann überhaupt
keine rede sein sondern dass wir
geeignete wege finden um normal davon
habe ich auch nicht normal und
geringverdiener zu entlasten und
insofern warten sie in rechter weise
wenn sie gesagt es habe keine
prioritäten der koalition das hat eine
hohe priorität wir sagt wollen wir am
ende etwas machen glück nichts mit den
praxistest besteht und nicht wie ein
spanier forderung erheben das kann ja
egal sein was dabei rauskommt die
wirklichen drückte deswegen nicht so ich
habe es deswegen so gesagt weil
vergangene woche eben ist ein ganz
klares nein gab und weil man jetzt weil
der druck zunimmt und weil die
spritpreise noch mal um 20 30 cent
gestiegen sind in dieser woche dann
jetzt langsam überlegt und was auf dem
weg bringt das wirkt jetzt nicht die
oberste priorität manche sachen gehen ja
auch ganz ganz schnell dann aber schauen
wir noch mal drauf wie im moment die
mehrheiten verteilt sind hier in
deutschland jetzt können sie sagen für
steuersenkungen sind immer alle das
zeigen aber die umfragen gar nicht das
zeigt aber diese aktuelle umfrage die
wir durchgeführt haben am freitag mit
hilfe des meinungsforschungsinstituts
insel sowie haben gefragt sind sie
aktuell dafür dass der finanzminister
dass die bundesregierung an der
steuerschraube auf benzin dreht und das
ist eine überragende mehrheit
86,7 prozent der deutschen sind der
auffassung da muss der staat etwas tun
und da wird auch herr der vermutlich der
ein oder andere fdp-wähler dabei sein
und der ein oder andere der auch ihnen
an die bundesregierung verholfen hat
weil man dachte die fdp ach ja die steht
ja auch dafür dass steuern gesenkt
werden
und das tut sie lieber erweise deswegen
werden wir natürlich pendler entlasten
das ist das was herr steg nach vorn
gesagt hat im ersten paket was bereits
beschlossen ist ein weiteres wird folgen
nur mit verlaub wenn jetzt ersparen dass
da gerade küchen ökonomie denn wir
wissen dass der gesamtstaat
mindereinnahmen hat insbesondere der
bund das ist bereits fakt also wenn er
öffentlich sagt hätte insgesamt
mehreinnahmen ist es schlicht die
unwahrheit um das reine zu sagen und zum
zweiten muss man ihnen fragen
gleichzeitig wo diese preise so stark
explodieren sagt die union wir müssen
einen sofortigen lieferstopp ein
sofortiges importverbot für russische
rohstoffe haben also für erdöl und so
weiter das passt mit verlaub aber das
ist der punkt ja oder wollen wir ja die
märchen die hatte ja gut nachvollziehen
darüber wollen wir schmecken herrsche
und möglicherweise werden weder wie man
entlastung finanziert noch wie das ganze
laufen soll das ist schwierig als
opposition ich habe immer gesagt man
muss qualitäts opposition seien die
pakete bei der cdu der ok das sparen wir
uns auch für nach der sendung tragen sie
es nach der sendung aus kurz unwichtig
hier küchenpsychologie hat erst mal
gesessen bayern sparen jetzt nehmen wir
uns aber das mit was sie gerade gesagt
haben da geht es um die sanktionen also
das ist ja tatsächlich das dilemma indem
wir stecken ja sie haben es auch zu
beginn der sendung gleich angesprochen
einerseits regen wir uns natürlich über
hohe spritpreise auf weil sie uns eben
belasten im eigenen portemonnaie das
merken wir eben einfach seit 14 tagen
und sowieso schon wegen der steigenden
inflation und gleichzeitig sind fünf
wird maximal scharfe maßnahmen und das
ja auch völlig berechtigt schauen sie
was der ukrainische botschafter in
diesen tagen am samstag nochmal
getwittert hat er hat einfach mal
nachrechnen lassen was überweisen wir
aktuell eigentlich noch nach russland
und unten stets die zahl unten ist
entscheidend das war am freitag der
stand 9 milliarden euro nach russland
gegangen für gas und öl von dort für
putins cars also das sind die summen
seit kriegsbeginn überwiesen von
deutschland nach russland
kann es da überhaupt herr stegner eine
andere lösung geben als raus aus
russischem gas und öl wenn wir diese
zahlen sehen und ganz genau wissen wie
viele von den bomben und raketen aktuell
deutschland finanziert sind
das finde ich eine polemische zuspitzung
die ich nicht teilen würde aber gerne
mit ist also ich finde so kann man das
nicht sagen aber ich will ihnen sagen
die reaktion auf den krieg ist ja die
was am sonntag von einer woche gesagt
worden ist im deutschen bundestag dass
wir auch uns unabhängiger machen müssen
von
russischem öl und gas aber müssen wir
leben dass wir die verschiedenen neben
den neben den anderen maßen was wir aber
nicht wollen können es gibt ja ein paar
dinge die wir nicht tun wir beteiligen
uns an als nato nicht an diesem krieg
aus guten gründen ist ja auch eine denkt
intellektuell denkbar machen wir aus
guten gründen nicht weiter
brandgefährlich und sanktionen gegen
putin zu machen die am ende und selbst
die stabilisieren und zwar komplett über
das hinaus was wir leisten müssen an
solidarität das wäre doch ein sieg für
herrn putin den wir ihm glaube ich nicht
geschehen sollten und da gibt es im
länder die in unterschiedliche
situationen sind für deutschland gilt
das für italien für ein paar andere auch
leben in der sagen wir brauchen ein
bisschen dazu das sagt hat die
aussenminister der bundeskanzler und
dann ist es ganz leicht hat sowieso
hinzustellen und zu sagen jetzt machen
wir das sofort wir sind für die folgen
ja nicht verantwortlich und gleichzeitig
fordern wir die entlastung und dann
hören sie mal leute kann ja ja keine
linksradikalen hören sie mal was die
deutsche industrie uns zum beispiel satz
in diesem thema und das muss man
bedenken und natürlich gibt es nicht nur
die wahl zwischen schwarz und weiß und
manchmal ist es auch grau wir würden
lieber heute als morgen rausgehen aber
ich glaube es ist im augenblick nicht
vertretbar sozusagen sofort alle
lieferungen einzustellen das ist markt
falsche politik der vergangenheit
gewesen sein und wir müssen aber weiter
an da heißt es auch überdenken was war
polemisch rz gegner um das noch zu
verstehen weil zehn milliarden haben
oder nicht das ist ja das herz
entscheiden ab nämlich polemisch war
dass sie gesagt haben dass wir sozusagen
willentlich quasi die raketen
finanzieren die mit finanzieller das ist
das ist nicht der fall warum ist es
gerade der fall gibt es auch viele dass
die sagen muss dann kann mit seinen
wiesen gar nichts mehr anfangen wir
schließen die von
wir schließen die vom internet
bankensystem weitgehend aus die
sanktionen haben beginnen gerade zu
wirken und sie sind schmerzhaft wie man
hört und man muss sehen wie sich das
entwickelt aber jedenfalls sind hier
nicht in der situation nach allem was
ich weiß nach allem was experten und
sagen allem was die wirtschaft und sagte
sofort raus zu gehen jedenfalls was das
betrifft und deswegen finde ich hat man
als bundesregierung als politik schon
auch die verantwortung mit zu bedenken
was die nebenwirkungen sind wenn ihr
neben auf ihre teams auf jeden die
hauptwirkung dann gibt es ein großes wir
alle wissen wie schreibt man das ist so
und wir alle wissen welches versagen da
in der vergangenheit auch vorliegt und
dass ihnen das mit ans bein gebunden
wurde im moment in der regierung hätte
zumindest ihnen die sie in den
vergangenen jahren nicht immer beteiligt
waren in der regierung aber ist das
problem ist also wenn wir sagen
natürlich finanzieren wir im moment
putins krieg mit was gibt es dagegen zu
sagen das ist genauso das findet gerade
statt
ja das würde unterstellen dass das so
finanzieren kann und da ist ein punkt
wichtig für die hintergrund zu wissen
dass harte schwert war die abkopplung
der russischen zentralbank das war das
harte schwert der rubel ist ja im freien
fall genau deshalb gewesen man würde ja
unterstellen wieder immer geld
hinfließen würde von uns hätten gar
keine probleme sie haben massive
wirtschaftliche probleme und das waren
sehr intelligente sanktionen wo der
westen komplett einig war dass es auch
selten genug der fall die sehr hart
russland und seine wirtschaft und
insbesondere die währung und das regime
von putin getroffen haben ich würde am
liebsten natürlich früher als als lieber
früher anders sein uns erdgas und erdöl
lieferung aus russland ausstatters ist
ein realistisches datum hätte so
zusammen wir drehen das jetzt einfach
das ein realistisches datum kann ich
nicht sagen das hängt damit zusammen wie
schnell und wir arbeiten intensiv gerade
daran und andere quellen erschließen wir
können das national machen ausbau
erneuerbare das dauert eine gewisse zeit
was wir jetzt in turbo geschwindigkeit
hin müssen sind andere energieimporte
wir im team ja bereits jetzt schon viel
stärker als die alte bundesregierung
noch flüssigkeit es beispielsweise so
wie sie mit hochdruck dabei gerade alle
alternativen insbesondere über den
sommer hinweg sofort zu nutzen dann
ruhig dafür auch einen höheren preis zu
zahlen damit wir sukzessive das andere
abschalten gar keine frage es gab
weitere zusagen einer tanksäule soll das
nicht steigen der preis aber
andererseits schalten wir was ab was die
erdgas und erdöl die fahrer aus russland
betrifft das mit verlaub das ist schon
populistisch nee das ist gesund aber
aber jetzt ersparen sie fordern das ja
bzw friedrich mehr als ihr parteichef
fordert dass jetzt neuerdings raus aus
nord stream 1 hat er diese woche
gefordert im laufe dieser woche auch
seine meinung verändert aber jetzt ist
an diesem punkt angekommen das heißt sie
halten das für jetzt realistisch was
herr dürr und was herr stegner aktuell
ausschließen dass das überhaupt
funktionieren würde erst mal wenn ich
auch nochmal grundsätzlich darf ein
schritt zurück wir müssen tatsächlich
sehen und ich würde das jetzt gar nicht
so parteipolitisch machen weil das war
ja ein breiter gesellschaftlicher
konsens dass wir die energiewende wollen
dass wir kohle und kernenergie ausstieg
als einziges industrieland der welt
gleichzeitig machen ist
gesellschaftlicher konsens gewesen wir
haben unseren anteil und unsere
verantwortung aber ich find das jetzt
irgendwie zu einfach dass immer alles
parteipolitisch wird sondern das waren
wie ich den wir als deutschland ja
gegangen sind und dieser weg ist es
wichtig dieser welt diese these dieser
weg hat uns abhängig gemacht von
russischem gas das ist ja die wahrheit
weil wir diesen weg so gegangen sind
sind wir abhängiger geworden von
abhängigen hatte sie immer bestritten
haben beziehungsweise ihre kanzlerin
christ naja es ist ich sage noch einmal
das können als alles so machen aber das
ist ein weg den dieses land wie fdp
hatte in teilen sie gegangen sind genau
die die wie das land in großer mehrheit
also der kohleausstieg der kernenergie
ausgenommen aber das ist mehrere
anfordert breiter gesellschaft das ist
mein verein fast und die haben wir hier
waren fand und übernehmen verantwortung
für die lage sage ich auch gerne noch
einmal war das wichtig ist ob manchmal
für die innenpolitischen debatten ist
putin mit seinem angriff auf die ukraine
und den folgen die b 3 aus warum jetzt
geht es darum wie werden wenn dich nur
fossil frei sondern wir werden wir putin
frei in unserer energie fördern und das
ist noch dringlicher aus meiner sicht
als fossil frei ist putin frei wann dazu
gehören jetzt lassen sie mich das ist
eine frage die ist etwas komplexer als
sehr komplex wird das auch gerne mit
heißem herz beantworten weil angesichts
der bilder die wir jeden tag sehen ja
möchte man am liebsten sagen heute jetzt
sofort ex abba und kommt die frage
ist ja richtig dass das eben nicht mit
heißen herd sondern auch mit kühlem kopf
wir haben eine verantwortung haben und
deswegen möchte ich das einfach mal wenn
sie gestatten nur bei 23 gedanken dazu
sagen das erste ist ich finde wir
brauchen ganz schnell eine analyse ein
konzept der bundesregierung was machen
wir eigentlich wenn putin selbst ab
stellt morgen am tag da musste ja und
jenseits von einzelinterviews am altar
analyse her was bedeutet das für
deutschland was bedeutet das für die
preise was bedeutet das für die
wirtschaft in morgen abstellt zweitens
wie werden wir aus meiner sicht
idealerweise bis zum winter 2023 24
putin frei in unserer energieversorgung
wie kann das gehen wir sind die schritte
dahin erste leichtere schritte sind
kohle und öl die sind leichter auf dem
weltmarkt zu ersetzen kann man auch
woanders einkaufen und auch
transportieren vor allem gas ist
schwieriger weil vor allem pipeline
gebunden und auch da braucht es eine
abfolge und deswegen haben wir ja gesagt
das eben in diesem gesamtkonzept das
abschalten von horst im einst als
einzige pipeline die direkt nach
deutschland geht nicht durch andere
europäische länder daneben ein erster
schritt sein kann ein schritt
offensichtlich die auch eine balance
erhält in diesem gesamtkonzept aber ich
bin da manchmal wissen sie das ist wie
diese kommunikation ist ja auch sagt
robert habeck einerseits wenn putin
morgen abstellt kriegen wir hin ist
nicht so schlimm bis ende des sommers
ist alles safer sax ganz schreibt er hat
ja gesagt jetzt sagt er jetzt mit der
unabhängigkeit das war noch in kutte
darstellt kriegen wir hin wenn wir aktiv
rausgehen wird alles ganz furchtbar so
das sind zwei interviews wieder
innerhalb von zwei wochen mit ganz
unterschiedlicher tonlage und deswegen
möchte ich und ich finde das hat das
parlament auch verdient und die deutsche
öffentlichkeit einfach mal eine analyse
und ein konzept dazu wir schlafen ganz
kurz durch ersparen abschlussrunde in
dieser oder abschlussfrage in dieser
runde ganz kurz wenn wir die ganze
corona zeit erlebt haben und jetzt uns
mitten im krieg befinden relativiert
dass auch ihren blick auf das was wir an
krise erlebt haben an corona krise
relativieren ist nicht ist zeigt ich
finde die pandemie hat schon gezeigt und
dieser krieg zeigt es in europa weniger
flugshow nähe von berlin dass dinge die
wir für selbstverständlich gehalten
haben alles andere als
selbstverständlich sind und die pandemie
hat durchaus sozusagen versäumnisse im
land deutlich gemacht thema digitale
thema vorsorge und dieser krieg macht
eben auch versäumnisse in der außen-
sicherheits- und energiepolitik deutlich
ja ich sage noch einmal das ist eine
verantwortung aus der wir uns ja auch
nicht völlig raus ziehen aber es ist
auch eine verantwortung in der
gesamtgesellschaftlichen debatte
deutschland kommt an bestimmten stellen
stichwort zeitenwende am anfang dieses
jahrzehnts das hat die pandemie gezeigt
dass zeigte krieg in eine ganz neue lage
ich danke erst einmal in dieser runde
ralf stegner christian doerr jens spahn
wir halten fest dass von der opposition
eine klare steuersenkungsforderungen
kommt die das aber nicht umsetzen muss
und die beiden dirigieren christian dörr
und ralf stegner die sind noch etwas
zurückhaltend kündigen aber für diese
woche einen weiteren
entlastungsschritt an vermutlich nicht
durch steuersenkung beim sprit so der
aktuelle stand hier aus die richtigen
fragen bei bild wir sind nach der kurzen
pause zurück
[Musik]
zurück bei den richtigen fragen hierbei
bild wo wir bis eben leidenschaftlich
über den spritpreis gestritten haben
über steuersenkungen auf den spritpreis
aber was sind schon unsere problemchen
hier in deutschland gegen das war es die
ukraine im moment aushalten müssen gegen
tausende tote dort mittlerweile gerade
kommt die meldung rein allein in mario
pohl über 2000 zivilisten getötet allein
in dieser stadt darüber wollen wir
sprechen jetzt über die militärische
lage im land in der ukraine und das tun
wir mit zwei tollen gästen hierbei bild
nämlich herzlich willkommen und sehr
großer schock der uns zugeschaltet ist
aus der ukraine aus dem westen der
ukraine
er ist dort hervorragend deutsch
sprechen militärchef einer region im
westen der ukraine nämlich zinnowitz
begrüßen sie herzlich häuser zog und ich
begrüße herzlich als lothar domröse den
langjährigen nato-general bei uns herr
usa zog zuerst langem eine hagere
über ihn wenn wir herr uhr sa job so
leidenschaftlich hier gerade über unsere
problemchen gestritten haben über ein
paar leere supermarktregale wo es gerade
keine rapsöl mehr gibt wo es
toilettenpapier knapp wird wo wir
aktuell
rekordpreise beim sprit erleben wie
empfinden sie eine solche debatte in
deutschland
vor allem möchte ich großes kompliment
und wirklich
ihnen persönlich respekt auch zum
ausdruck blinken die bausätze und
minuten die ich zu sehen und zu hören
durfte wie sie dass moderiert haben ich
danke ihnen vielmals für die scharfen
konkret mit und die wichtigen und
richtigen fragen und ich möchte sagen
dass wir alle einfach aufwachen sollen
der tag 18 des vernichtungskrieges
seitens russlands bedeutet nichts
anderes als dass der putin die ganze
welt die ganze europäische union einfach
prüft ob die
langjährigen jahrzehnte lange
konstruktion vom werte gesellschaften
eine illusion ist
ein im sinne putins und zaristischen
russlands potemkinsches dorf nur von
einer fassade oder tatsächlich ist das
ein fundament des nachkriegs europas auf
dem das ganze heute feststeht oder ist
das nur eine wirtschaftsunion die vor
allem jetzt zieht er
wirtschaftliche nachteile aus dem krieg
einbüßen zu müssen können sie uns sagen
herbert schott wieder ihrer antwort im
moment ihre bewertung ausfällt ich
fürchte nicht so gut ich fürchte dass
wir als wertegemeinschaft zu der wir ja
auf jeden fall auch sie auf jeden fall
die ukraine zählen mit ihren
demokratischen werten dass wir ja aus
ihrer sicht alles tun bisher um diese
werte gemeinschaft zu pflegen schauen
sie wir haben jetzt einen wirklich
fürchterlichen menschen mord in der
ukraine mit phosphorbomben mit kassetten
bomben und die menschen glühen aus
diesen überhitzten temperaturen und
werden vernichtet wie einst in den
schrecklichsten kriegen und das ist kein
kino
ich möchte alle bitten und appelliert
bitte schauen sie dass sich nicht an wie
ein vielen das ist nicht irgendein
bericht über die vor
vorgang würden vorgang eines krieges für
militärakademie oder für historischen
unterricht das ist realität von heute
und bitte erinnern sie sich alle wie die
vorgänge im zweiten weltkrieg waren und
wie viele ausreden mussten damals die
juden europas sich anhören warum sie aus
konzentrationslagern nicht raus durften
und mussten sterben es ist einfach ein
einfaches beispiel und man muss diese
parallelen heute sehr laut und offen
anführen und sprechen frage ist wie und
wer hier davon uns dagegen tun kann um
den krieg zu stoppen ich bin einfach
überwältigt von den bildern aus berlin
von heute
abertausende von menschen sind
solidarisch mit der ukraine das heißt in
der demokratischen freien deutschen welt
in der gesellschaft hat die politik das
mandat schnell zu agieren um den busen
zu stoppen deswegen müssen die politik
werden nicht wei klinge bleiben
entschuldigen sie diesen direkten
ausdruck nicht sich gegen irgendwelche
versprechungen mit smarter oder anderen
irgendwie verstecken sondern direkt
sagen wir können den krieg stoppen wenn
wir den mut ihn hart und sofort
zurückweisen und betonen den frieden in
europa ist das wichtigste fundament nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg ohne
verzeihen sich herzog wollte einmal kurz
ein domröse mit in die runde holen denn
das sind glasklare worte natürlich aus
der ukraine nicht zuschauen wie in einem
film und vor allen dingen der satz
bleibt hängen der usa zog putin prüft
uns alle gerade wie stehen wir zusammen
in dieser wertegemeinschaft das was
heute passiert ist im westen in der
ukraine das ist der nächste punkt in
dieser prüfung das ist ein
raketenangriff ganz in der nähe vom nato
gebiet gewesen heute bei lemberg 20
kilometer entfernt von der polnischen
grenze das heißt war das heute der
nächste punkt der prüfung war das heute
ein warnschuss der nächste warnschuss an
die nato
nein das würde ich so nicht sehen
zunächst war sie mich ausdrücken dafür
serie und für alle ukraine meinen
tiefsten respekt für ihre tapferkeit und
für ihre standfestigkeit das ist gar
keine
ich muss die politik nun alles irgendwie
der general nicht unbedingt in schutz
nehmen aber die bundesrepublik
deutschland zusammen mit der narbe hat
immer klar kann man von dezember an dass
die narbe hier nicht einschaltet also
eine militärische ein militärschlag ist
zum derzeitigen zeitpunkt ausgeschlossen
aus westlicher sicht die waffe nicht
gleich hohe haben sich gewandelt wie man
weiß in deutschland speziell von keiner
waffenlieferungen erhebliche mengen wenn
ich sehe was der amerikanische präsident
die kamera angeschlossen haben weitere
millionen und tausende von abwarten und
dann ist was luftabwehr wird geprüft es
sind alles richtig und wichtig aber
richtig ist auch dass die ukraine hier
für freiheit und demokratie für uns alle
steht und kempf und ich kann verstehen
dass du nicht alleinige fühlen aber so
sind nicht spüre ich bedauerlicherweise
was passiert denn herr domröse wenn
putin diese waffenlieferungen gezielt
bombardieren lässt sei es auf
ukrainische staatsgebiet oder auch
jenseits der ukrainischen grenze
ich glaube nicht dass er den krieg
ausweiten würden ich kann mir schwer
vorstellen ich mein wissen tue ich
natürlich nicht aber ich glaube schon
dass er auch nach dem gebiet machen
würde jeder zentimeter aufnahme mit
heißt krieg war letzten station wird es
heißen eine verletzung ist eine
besetzung und dann sind wir drin das
kann ich nicht gebrauchen denn
militärisch stellt er sich ausgesprochen
ungeschickt an ich spreche nicht vom
präsident aber von seinen genau was sie
dort machen ist weiße ware also
niederschlagen aber sie können nicht
operieren sind nicht an ihn im kopf sind
nicht taktisch vernetzt und der kann
jetzt eins nicht gebrauchen denn die
narbe streitkräfte gegen sich das wird
er nicht machen wenn er sich in der
ukraine angreift aufzügen genau weiß
intel
durch aufklärung und weil in dem zug
sitzen die raketen dann ist natürlich
sein recht an ist auch ein militärisches
ziel das ist das risiko immer wir sind
heute an kriegstag 18 herzog womit
rechnen sie für diese woche rechnen sie
damit dass putins truppen weiter ins
land vordringen möglicherweise auch
einen kurzfristigen sozusagen sieg für
sich verzeichnen können rechnen sie
damit dass kirche in den nächsten tagen
möglicherweise nicht gehalten werden
kann ich möchte klar sagen über den sieg
in der ukraine banken nur träumen in
seinen schrecklichen nächtlichen kurzen
träumen aber er wird das nie bekommen
denn die ukraine wird sich nie ergeben
wir werden nie aufgeben und eine robe
und besessen und sieg über die prämie
ist überhaupt nicht möglich
zeitweise sind kurzen besetzenden
einzelner bezirke oder gemeinden ist gar
nicht der krieg der sieg über die
ukraine
das ist nur zu zu kurze kontrolle über
einzelnen teilen dem ringe und das
wichtigste ist wir sind 40 millionen
starkes volk wir sind einheitlich wie
nie und deswegen werden wir unbedingt
auch zu millionen wieder und wieder in
unsere armee beitreten und kämpfen dafür
bräuchten wir nur wirklich machen damit
wir uns von den luftangriffen schützen
können und dass es nichts anderes wir
laden nicht ein deutscher oder
nato-soldaten soldaten hin zu uns zu
kommen und mit uns zu kämpfen wir
verlangen nur von der freien welt von
den starken bagger und hoffentlich
freunden hilft uns luft über die ukraine
zu schützen zu schließen damit wir
luftangriffe vorbeugen und abwehren
können damit unsere frauen kinder und
alle anderen zivilisten nicht sterben
müssen durch
bombardieren und wie im zweiten
weltkrieg und das wichtigste und
schlimmste was passieren kann sind
terroranschläge von putins
spezialeinheiten zu den atomkraftwerken
chemiebetrieben ukraine ist man jetzt
sollen wir liga alarm das ist bei ihnen
der alarm kam der usa
ist das bei ihnen der alarm den wir
hören gerade nein das ist nicht passiert
dann ist es auf unseren bildern das
müssen wir einmal kurz erklären das sei
bei ihnen gerade im westen kurze frage
noch an sie domröse halten sie es für
möglich kiew weiter langfristig zu
halten
[Musik]
müssen dass man von angriffen auf alle
wir müssen das aus tschetschenien
wir müssen selbst austreten alle gewalt
des gegners ist mächtig in diesem fall
und er könnte im schlimmsten fall das
ding in schutt und asche legen was wir
nicht hoffen im einzelnen zu sagen die
strategische zielsetzungen weiterführen
kann
er kann nicht
die gesamte ukraine zu infizieren und zu
entwaffnen wie er das gemeinerweise
nennen das wird denn nie schaffen wir
sehen ja dass er noch nicht mal im
bombast begrüßt wird von den frauen die
er ja befreien will und in kinder also
das ganze land gern vergessen aber weit
über 500.000 mal das schafft er nicht
muss ich leider auch sagen dass der von
mir zutiefst bewunderte präsident selber
ins kino lenski auch sein ziel wie creme
und den dom was zurückzukriegen auch
wird nicht erreichen können insofern
muss irgendwann zu einem zeitpunkt um
blutvergießen zu stoppen und zerstörung
zu stoppen irgendwann müssen die bei
präsident zum ergebnis kommen wenn wir
beide unsere maximale zielsetzung nicht
erreichen müssen wir warnen was ist gut
genug danke und da fand ich den
vorschlag vom potenziellen wenn ich das
sagen darf sehr weitreichend sehr mutig
zu sagen okay über die krim reden wir
jetzt nicht wir reden nicht über diese
sogenannten unabhängigen wieder blicken
aber
ich lebe so garnadt wir neutral sein
aber da haben wir uns neutral wollen sie
beide seien ja nur neutral im seelands
wir sind in unserem sinne ist west
neutral das heißt freie wahl eu
perspektive und brüten sind neutral
meister und ist ja gerade tatsächlich
bewegung drin in diesen verhandlungen
wir danken sehr für ihre einschätzung
hierbei bild hans lothar domröse
langjähriger nato-general und sehr
großer schock herzliche grüße alles gute
in der ukraine danke ihnen wir machen
eine kurze pause sind gleich zurück bild
live
[Musik]